THURSDAY REIMER.
ALONE THERE.NIGHT, GAME
ON THE POWER PLAY.
ZONE. S THAT,
BRENT BURNS WITH AN ASSIST.
FIVE TAKEAWAYS OVER 26 MINUTES.
A SHOT B Randy:
THAT'S OFF THE BLOCK.
>> PICKED UP B
BLACKWELL GETS A SHOT T  BY
BLACKWELL.
HERE'S ANOTHER CHANCE FOR
SEATTLE,A SAN JOSE SHARKS.ANY T
THE HIGH SLOT..
MORGAN GEEKIE.
ONE MINUS ONE. JUST LONG ENOUGHE
TO COME IN AND PICK UP THE
LOOSE CHANGE.
NOW GEEKIE'S GOTNTO THE
STRETCH OF EIGHT STRAIGHT GAME.
WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE IF THEY'D
BEEN ABLE TO HOLD THE LEAD
LONGER THAN NINE S
AND WHEN HE DID, IT OPENED UP .
JOHANSSON WAS POSTED UP  RIGHT
IN FRONT OF  WORD.
SEASON FOR SEATTLE.  SCOTT REED
DAGGERS.S
CALIFORNIA.
HERE'S A TURNOVER, A CHANCE  ME
BACK ENTER BY DE OF THE NET.
JOHANSSON, EBERLE, AND REIMER
MADE THE SAVE. FRONT. FT-HAND SS
GOING TO COME IN BEHIND, AND
RIGHT THERE GET THE PA
THE SHOT FROM BRENT BURNS FINDS
A LITTLE